All right.
So, here we go. So, reliable delivery.
This is a definition that we wrote down
before. Um so,
we said, "Let P1 be a process that sends
message M to process P2.
If neither P1 nor P2 crashes, and then
we put this asterisk here, uh then P2
eventually delivers M."
the message. So, I put this asterisk.
So, what does uh
What What does that as- asterisk
represent? I mentioned last time that
different people define reliable
delivery in different ways. Uh so, what
goes there is um
another part of the definition, which is
"and did not
all messages are lost."
Um so, do we need that part that says,
"And not all messages are lost"?
Well, it depends, right? If we're
working under the crash model or the the
omission model.
So, if we were working under the crash
model, then the only kinds of failures
that can occur in the crash model, which
we talked about last time, are processes
crashing, right? Uh and so, we need to
have this uh
disclaimer, "If neither P1 nor P2
crashes." Uh but, we don't need to have
this other disclaimer about messages
being lost. On the other hand, if we're
in the omission model, then we could
have the crashing or we could have
messages being lost. So, then we need to
have that piece in there as well.
Uh so,
we need to have this part if we're on if
we're working under the omission model.
Which do you think is more realistic,
the crash model or the omission model?
So we're getting some different answers
from different people. Uh,
folks are some people on Slack are
saying crash. Uh,
people on Twitch are saying omission. So
I would say the omission model is is
more realistic uh because
the omission model recall the crash
model
uh recall that crash failures are are a
subset of omission failures. So if we
handle omission failures uh then we're
handle handling crash failures as well.
And uh omission failures are are
actually quite common uh in practice. So
we need to have this expert bidding here
as well.
So we'd better have that assumption.
Okay.
Although this is a little bit annoying
that the definition of reliable delivery
differs depending on which fault model
we're working in. So uh so we'll come
back to that later.
All right. How are we going to implement
reliable delivery? If Alice has to get a
message to Bob, how can she do so
reliably?
Any suggestions?
Yeah, yeah, okay. Uh handled by TCP.
Right. Uh but let's say that we are
implementing TCP.
Yeah, so there's a good suggestion in
chat. Uh
just keep sending messages over and over
until you get an ack, right?
So if Alice wants to send a message,
then
she puts it into some sort of send
buffer on her side, right?
So she sends the message,
and it goes into the send buffer,
uh and she has a timeout on her side. So
the algorithm goes like this.
Whenever the timeout expires, you send
what's in the send buffer, and you reset
the timeout, uh but you don't delete it
from the buffer yet.
And then you just keep on sending the
message, right?
And then, you know, maybe some of those
are lost, uh
maybe some of them are slow, whatever,
um but at some point,
hopefully a message will get through,
and then at that point, uh
Bob will send an acknowledgement. Uh and
then if you receive the acknowledgement,
then you can then you can stop sending
the message and delete that message from
the send buffer.
Um so some people are asking in chat,
"What is an ack?" Ack is just short for
acknowledgement.
So, this is the acknowledgement message
from Bob.
So, whenever an ACK is received
for a sent message, you can just delete
that message from the send buffer.
What issues are there with this
implementation?
Well,
somebody already pointed out in chat
that uh
this doesn't solve the two generals
problem that we talked about last time.
And indeed, it doesn't. Uh so, Alice can
be sure that Bob got the message, right?
Because she gets the acknowledgement.
So, there's certainty on the sender's
side. Uh but there's not certainty on
Bob's side
uh
that Alice got the acknowledgement. Uh
so, it doesn't solve the two generals
problem.
So, one issue with this implementation
is
well, what if the ACK gets dropped,
right? What if this message here gets
dropped? Then Alice will keep sending.
Uh we know that eventually some ACK will
get through because the specification of
the protocol we're trying to implement
has this and not all messages are lost.
Um but what would it mean if Bob's ACK
was dropped, right? It would mean that
Bob gets Alice's message twice or it
could mean that, right? So, or even just
if some of even if some of Alice's
messages were slow, right? So, we could
have a scenario like this.
Notice we're not talking about uh
um we haven't said anything about FIFO.
We're just talking about reliable
delivery. So, so in principle, some of
Alice's messages could cross over in the
channel, right? Uh
so, we could get something like this um
where Bob would send it maybe Bob would
send an ack here.
This message up here was slow. Alice
gets here, right? Uh she hasn't received
any ack yet. Um so she's sent the So
she's sending a second message. Bob acks
the message here. Um but then Bob
receives the message again.
So Bob gets a message twice
in this setup.
Or this could even happen uh
let's say that this even even if you did
guarantee FIFO, what if this message up
here just got lost for whatever reason?
Do you think it's a problem for Bob to
get a message twice?
Well, I think it depends on the message,
right? Uh so in fact, when we were
talking about workarounds for the two
generals problem, one of the workarounds
we came up with relied on sending the
same message again and again until we
got an ack, right? And assuming that it
would be okay if more than one could get
through, right? So it So it looked like
this.
Alice would send
attack at dawn
over and over and over.
If Bob got one, he would say, "Okay."
So we're imagining here that Bob
actually got the first message from
Alice and he acknowledged it. Um but
maybe it took a while for the ack to
arrive, so he got a couple of extra
copies maybe of the attack at dawn
message from her.
Um but do those messages actually change
his mind, Right? Like, is he going to
say, "Oh, she said attack at dawn twice.
Does that mean she doesn't really want
to attack at dawn?"
No. In this case, it's not going to mean
anything different for Bob if he gets a
duplicate of the attack at dawn message.
But in general, some messages have this
property and others do not.
Um so, let's say that you're assigning a
value to a key in a key-value store,
right?
So,
say I I'm I'm a client here.
And here's the key-value store.
And I send the message
First, let's say I send the message uh
assign three to X.
And let's say that that one gets
duplicated.
So, if that message gets duplicated, is
that a problem?
Yeah, no. I wouldn't say that this one
is a problem, right? I get the messages
on the key-value store side and I get
assign three to X and then again, assign
three to X.
So, is the result going to be the same
as if I had only done the assignment
once? Yeah, it would. On the other hand,
if this were the message,
if the message were increment X,
would that one be okay to duplicate?
No, it would not. No, because doing
increment X twice uh is different from
doing increment X once.
So,
the word for a message that it's okay to
receive more than once
or a function that it's okay to run more
than once
is item potent.
So,
mathematically speaking, we say that a
function f
is item potent
if uh
f of x
equals
f of f of x
which means that it's equal to f of f of
f
of x
and so on.
So,
assigning to a variable like this
is item potent, but incrementing a
variable is non-item potent.
And item potents end up ends up being
really important in distributed systems
because generally speaking, a good way
to make sure something gets done
is to try to do it a bunch of times
until at least one attempt succeeds.
And this uh so, it's it's going to be
useful if we can design systems in such
a way uh that messages are item potent.
So, this isn't always going to be
possible, right? Because sometimes we
need operations that aren't item potent,
but generally speaking, we'll have an
easier time of it if we're working with
item potent operations.
So, what this has to do with reliable
delivery is that in order to implement
reliable delivery, uh we typically need
to deliver a message more than once
sometimes.
Um so, reliable delivery uh is sometimes
called at least once delivery.
Okay.
So, reliable delivery is at least once.
What about at most once delivery? How do
you get that?
Yeah, it's really easy, right? Just send
a message.
If it arrives, great. If not, great,
right? Or even better, just don't do
anything.
So, at most delivery is uh
trivial to implement. Okay, so we got at
most once, and we got at least once.
What about exactly once delivery?
Is it even possible?
Yeah, somebody's asking on Twitch about
uh uh
the network model. So, yeah, uh for
everything we're talking about here,
we're assuming the asynchronous network
model.
So, I am not aware of a formal result
that says that exactly once delivery is
impossible.
But, I will say this,
when people out in the world claim that
their system provides exactly once
delivery,
usually what they mean is that the
messages were item potent anyway,
or that their application is written in
such a way that it deduplicates
messages.
So, when they say they have exactly once
delivery, usually that is dependent on
some other assumptions about their
system. So, my colleague Peter Alvaro
has some interesting thoughts on exactly
once delivery and the two generals
problem and how they both relate to that
concept of common knowledge that I
talked about last time.
So, if you want to know more about that,
uh talk to him.
Okay.
So,
today,
I want to start to talk about um
So, we we talked about implementing
reliable delivery, right? It mostly just
means send a bunch of messages until um
until you get an ack.
And because that's the approach that we
have, uh we have to assume that messages
may arrive more than once.
So, I want to I want to get into talking
about reliable broadcast now.
Um and that, I hope, will lead us uh
into a new topic.
Uh so, this class uh is mostly about
sending and receiving messages. We talk
about communication a lot, right? And a
lot of the communication we talk about
um is what's known as unicast
communication.
Uh so, what does that mean?
A unicast message has
one sender and one receiver.
So, unicast messages are one-to-one.
So, we briefly discussed broadcast
communication in the context of causal
broadcast. Um so, recall that that uh a
causal anomaly
might look like this.
But, we talked about how if we used uh
causal broadcast uh a causal broadcast
delivery protocol and we had tried to
deliver this message uh before that one,
then instead the first one would get
buffered, right? And it's And it would
only get delivered after the one that
was causally earlier had been received
and delivered.
Okay. So, we mentioned that this this
algorithm that we came up with uh for
ensuring causal delivery of messages was
specific to the case where broadcast
where where messages were broadcast
messages. It was a causal broadcast
algorithm.
Um
So, so what does broadcast mean? Uh
aside from all the all the causality
stuff, um what does broadcast mean? So,
broadcast messages we're going to say
are one-to-all.
And then there's multicast, uh which
means one to many, although not
necessarily all.
Have we seen any examples of multicast
yet?
Sure.
So our usual picture, well, okay, so one
one question here is when we say
broadcast, when we say everyone
receives, do we mean that you receive it
yourself as the sender or not? Um so,
the question is
only interesting if we want to be really
really pedantic about it, right? Because
if we were talking about, let's say,
uh this exchange of messages, right? Um
then we're calling that a broadcast
message. In principle, if you wanted to
say everyone received, then you'd have
to have a little self arrow here as
well.
Um but we usually leave that out. Uh
because it's not uh
it's not necessarily uh helpful to be
that pedantic. But even leaving that
aside, this question of do you deliver
to yourself or not? Yeah, the example of
um of a total order anomaly is an
example of multicast, right? Because
we have two clients here.
Client one sends
to these replicas, client two sends to
these replicas, but the clients aren't
talking to each other.
Um so this is an example of multicast.
Okay, so C1 sends to R1 and R2, but not
to C2, and C2 sends to R1 and R2, but
not to C1.
So, we aren't going to talk about how to
implement unicast messages in this
class. We are going to assume that there
is a built-in primitive to begin with
that lets you send a message from one
sender to one receiver.
But assuming that you had that built-in
primitive uh for implementing unicast
messages,
how could you go about implementing
broadcast and multicast?
Any suggestions?
Sure. Yeah, you could just implement it
by sending a series of unicast messages.
So,
if I'm Alice and I want to send a
message to Bob and Carol,
saying that Bob smells,
then
I can send it to Bob
and then almost at the same time,
I can send it to Carol.
So, under the hood,
these are actually separate unicast
messages.
But, the way that I want to think about
them is as having the same send event.
And in fact, that's the way that we have
been thinking of them all along, right?
The way that we've been been drawing
this picture up until now is that we've
had a single dot on this diagram with
multiple arrows coming out from it.
So,
when we draw multiple arrows with the
same start point, we're thinking of the
sends as being a single event, which is
as it should be. Uh but, under the hood,
you can imagine it being implemented as
the set of unicast messages. Uh and you
could imagine implementing this in a in
a transactional way.
Uh so that uh
if you um
so that you could you could maybe queue
up all the sends. Um but, but in the
end,
uh
that's only going to be so helpful,
right? Because uh
because unicast is uh is the only
primitive that you have. So,
that kind of leads us into this next
topic of how do how do we define
reliable broadcast?
So, and how do we implement reliable
broadcast? Um so, let's define it first,
actually.
So, I'm going to define reliable
broadcast this way.
We'll say,
if a correct process
delivers
a broadcast message
M
then all correct processes deliver M.
Before we get any further,
um
uh what do you think this correct
process thing means? Uh what is a
correct process?
Somebody just asked in chat uh are
broadcast messages also multicast
messages? Uh
I would say it's it's the other way
around actually. So, multicast means
sending to many recipients, potentially
all.
Um broadcast messages have to be to all.
Okay, so a suggestion in in chat is uh a
correct process is one that one that
isn't malicious. Um
so
I think it depends on your fault model
again, right? So,
if we were in the Byzantine fault model
where processes could be malicious,
right? Then you would certainly need to
guarantee that they're not malicious.
Um if you were working in the crash
model, then a correct process would just
be one that didn't crash.
Uh so
I mentioned that we had these two
different possible definitions of
reliable delivery, right? One of them
said that if process one sends a message
to process two, then if neither process
one nor process two crashes, then
process two eventually delivers the
message.
And then we also said uh okay, the same
thing, but also with this additional
caveat that not all messages are lost.
And the reason why
different people define reliable
delivery in different ways is that
they're working under the assumptions of
different fault models. So, if your
fault model is the crash model,
individual message loss isn't a thing.
So, in that if that's your fault model,
then it's okay to define something like
reliable delivery without mentioning
message loss. On the other hand, in the
omission model, message loss can occur.
So, we have to have that that um
disclaimer and not all messages are
lost.
Um and in the Byzantine model, we would
have to also say and neither of the
processes exhibit Byzantine behavior.
So,
it would really be nice if we could
define these properties uh in a way
that's not specific to the particular
fault model that we happen to be using
at the moment.
Um So, so we could do that, right? Um
like to pause this discussion of
reliable broadcast for a second to go
back to reliable delivery.
Uh
redux.
We could define it this way. We could
say
if a correct
process
P1 sends
a message
M
to a correct
process
P2
and then not all messages are lost.
Then P2 eventually delivers M.
So, what I've done here is
this is different from the definition I
had before. Before I just said that
neither P1 nor P2 to crash. Now, this
definition is more general because I
just say that I I say that P1 and P2 are
correct. If we're in the crash model,
that means that they don't crash. If
we're in the Byzantine model,
uh that means that they don't crash and
they also don't exhibit any Byzantine
behavior.
So, this definition is more general. Um
I've taken the meaning of what it what
it is to be a correct process in
different fault models and I've
abstracted over it.
So, we still had to have this not all
messages are lost thing in here.
Uh though, because if the fault model is
the omission model or any other fault
model that subsumes the omission model,
then message loss is something that can
happen aside from processes not being
correct.
So, anytime you see a definition like
this that says correct process,
the next question you want to ask
yourself is what is the fault model?
Because that'll tell you what it means
for something to be a correct process.
So, going back to reliable broadcast
now. Uh detour over.
Back to our definition of reliable
broadcast. This time we're just going to
use this correct process terminology
from the start.
Uh and we're just going to say this
definition is now general enough to
encompass any fault model that we might
be using.
Okay. So,
I want to talk about how you can
implement reliable broadcast.
And let's say
just for now
that we're working within the crash
model, so message loss doesn't happen,
but we have to confront the possibility
of processes crashing.
So,
how do we implement reliable broadcast?
Um
let's say we have Alice, Bob, and Carol.
Let's say Alice sends a message to Bob
and Carol.
And Bob
successfully delivers the message.
But Carol
receives the message, let's say, but I
won't put the check mark here because
let's say that Carol crashes
before she can deliver the message.
Does this violate
the reliable broadcast property that I
wrote down?
Somebody's saying yes.
Yeah, a couple people are saying yes. I
would I would argue that it doesn't,
right? Uh because it's about this
correct process piece. So, Carol
crashed, right?
So, she's not a correct process, right?
So, it's okay that she didn't deliver
the message because the assumption is
just that all correct processes
eventually deliver the message.
So, it's okay that she didn't deliver
the message uh because she didn't
satisfy this uh this premise of being a
a correct process.
But, how about this? Um so, we said a
little while ago that that broadcast is
actually implemented with unicast,
right? So, even though we would like to
pretend that Alice's broadcast message
was sent at a single moment in time,
um in reality, there were two points
where messages were sent here. So, if we
were to take this spot and actually like
zoom in on it
on Alice, it would actually look like
two different message sends here.
So, what if this happened? Um
what if Alice sent to Bob
uh and Bob delivered the message,
um
but then let's say Alice crashed
before she was able to send the message
to Carol,
and Carol went along not crashing.
Would this violate the reliable delivery
property?
What do you think?
Yeah, well, I think you could argue that
well, one thing you could argue is is
since Alice
didn't actually manage to finish
broadcasting the message then it wasn't
a broadcast message to begin with.
Um
but I think we could do a little better
than that. Um
so
I I would say that yes, this is in
violation of the spec.
Um so
if you don't like that, I guess you can
imagine that every message that's
supposed to be a broadcast message comes
with a tag on it that says hi, I'm a
broadcast message.
Um so even if the sender crashed before
sending to everybody, you can tell that
the message is in fact supposed to be
broadcast.
Okay, so
knowing that a process can crash in the
middle of trying to broadcast a message.
So and the reason why this is a
violation of of the spec, right? Is
because
so we say
if a correct process delivers a
broadcast message M, then all correct
processes deliver M.
So this doesn't say anything actually
about the correctness of the sending
process, right? It only talks about the
correctness of the process that delivers
the message. Recall that delivering is
something that you do after you receive
a message.
So
for the definition of reliable
broadcast, there's nothing in here about
the correctness of Alice, the one who's
sending the message. It's only about the
correctness of of the processes that
receive and deliver the message.
Um
so we so indeed, if Alice crashes here
uh
before going on to send the message to
Carol, then this does indeed violate
reliable broadcast.
Okay, so knowing that a process can
crash in the middle of trying to
broadcast a message.
Can anybody think of a way that we could
still have reliable broadcast?
So, knowing in particular that there
could be a crash right here,
right at the moment between sending a
message. And now that message is gone,
right? You can't take it back. And then
you can crash right there um before
sending the next unicast message that's
part of your overall broadcast.
Since you can crash at that point,
is there still a way that we could get
reliable broadcast?
Yeah. So, some people are starting to
come up with some good suggestions in
chat.
So,
I'm going to propose
the following protocol.
When you receive a message,
you don't deliver it yet.
Instead,
you you pass it on to everyone else.
And only once you've done that, do you
deliver it yourself. So, let's see how
that would work. So, Alice sends to Bob
and then crashes.
Bob gets the message, but instead of
delivering it immediately, he forwards a
copy of it on
uh to Alice and Carol.
And then he delivers it.
And Carol, when she gets the message,
she also forwards a copy to to Alice and
Bob.
And then delivers it.
So,
are there any problems here? What would
happen if Bob crashed right here before
sending to Carol?
Would that end up being a violation of
the protocol?
Or, excuse me, a violation of the
definition of of
reliable broadcast?
No, it wouldn't. Because then Bob would
never deliver the message himself. So,
the precondition of reliable broadcast
wouldn't be met, right? So, we're okay.
So,
here's a here's one sketch of an
algorithm for reliable broadcast.
We say
all processes
keep a set
of
delivered
messages
in their local state their local state.
When a process, let's call it P,
uh
wants to broadcast a message,
let's call it M,
it has to unicast that message
to all the processes
um
if but itself.
And then P
adds M
to
to its delivered set.
And we say
when P1 receives a message
from P2.
Let's call it M.
So when you receive a message
and
that message M
is in your delivered set,
then you don't need to do anything.
Because that means you know you already
know about the message.
Otherwise,
you unicast that message to everybody
but yourself and the one that sent it to
you.
And you add it to the delivered set.
So, some folks are asking, wouldn't this
result in a whole lot of messages being
sent?
Yes, absolutely.
So,
we'll talk about that in a second. So,
the way that it works is
every process is going to keep track of
messages that have been delivered to
them, right? So, we're going to assume
that if you're sending a message, then
then you know about it.
So,
if if you want to broadcast a message,
remember we're assuming that unicast is
a primitive that everybody has. So,
unicast is the is the primitive by which
we're implementing things like
broadcast. So,
you can then unicast to everybody but
yourself, and then you add that message
to your delivered set, meaning the
message has been delivered at yourself.
You can think of it as having sent it to
yourself and delivered it at yourself.
And then once when anybody receives a
message,
if they've already received and
delivered that message, then they don't
have to do anything, right? Otherwise,
they pass it on to everybody else, and
then they add it to their delivered set.
So, let's look at a couple more
scenarios.
Um
So, we already talked about this
situation where um where Alice sent a
message
to Bob
and then crashed
before she was able to also send it to
to Carol.
Um and we worked around that by saying,
well, when Bob receives the message,
he's going to forward it on to Carol. Uh
so, Carol will get the message.
Okay. Well,
what if Bob sends to Carol
and Alice?
And then let's say Bob crashes before he
can deliver the message to himself.
Well, is this a problem?
It shouldn't be. So, now everybody but
Carol has crashed, right? Because uh
Alice crashed right after sending to
Bob, and then Bob crashed after sending
to Alice and Carol. So, Carol now is the
only correct process.
Um so, at this point um
going back to our to our definition
of of what reliable broadcast is,
um
we say, if a correct process delivers a
broadcast message M, then all correct
processes deliver M. Well, we're now in
a scenario where there only is one
correct process. So, now whether or not
Carol delivers the message will still be
satisfying this property.
So, it turns out that this uh that this
protocol uh that I wrote down here
uh
this reliable broadcast algorithm,
it turns out it works in general.
Um
so,
you could have processes sending back to
wherever they received from,
um but that's unnecessary. So, as an
optimization, we can we can leave out
that message.
But, as some people have already pointed
out, um this protocol is going to result
in people receiving duplicate messages,
right?
So,
suppose nobody crashes, right?
then we'd have something like this.
So, even if we have that optimization
that you don't send a message back to
the sender, right?
If nobody crashes,
then when Bob receives this message, he
won't send it uh
back to Alice, but he doesn't know that
Carol got it, right? So, he'll send it
to Carol.
So, then Bob gets to deliver the message
after sending it to Carol. When Carol
gets this message from Alice, she
doesn't know that Bob got it as well, so
she had better send it to Bob.
And then she gets to deliver it.
So, even with the don't send back to the
sender optimization, we still have
duplicate messages here.
Um so, Bob and Carol each receive the
message twice. Um Bob receives it here
and here.
Uh Carol receives it here and here.
So, something that they can do,
right, is keep track of what messages
they've delivered.
And then if they receive one that
they've already delivered, like here,
um
then they don't have to deliver it
again.
Or here.
Um
So, what about forwarding? Now, if
they've already delivered it, do they
have to forward it again? No. That's
what that do nothing in the algorithm
is.
The fact that they already delivered it
means that they definitely already
forwarded it, too.
Okay. Any questions about any of this?
Uh one one person asked, "What's the
difference between forwarding and
delivering?" So, delivering a message,
recall that delivering a message means
that when you receive a message, it's as
though there's a a little mail clerk
hanging out on this process here who
decides what to do with that received
message. So, delivering a message means
that you then make it available to the
process. You are that mail clerk and you
get to decide, "Okay, this message is uh
is now available."
Um
and you can choose. So, delivering is is
something that you get to choose when to
do, which is why uh
it's such an important uh mechanism for
implementing things like causal
broadcast, which lets you queue up
messages and not deliver them until uh
uh
in in until it would make sense
causally.
So,
that's also a mechanism that we can use
here. We can wait to deliver a received
message until we forward it to everybody
else. So, forwarding is just sending,
sending to everybody else.
So, a big idea that I want to leave you
with here, um which we saw when we
talked about reliable delivery, and now
we're also seeing with reliable
broadcast,
is this idea that fault tolerance often
involves making copies of things.
So, in the case of reliable delivery, we
were able to tolerate message loss by
just sending multiple copies of a
message until at least one got through.
In the case of reliable broadcast,
we're able to tolerate processes
crashing by making copies of received
messages and forwarding them.
So, this notion of fault tolerance
involving making copies is going to
become important as we get into the next
part of the course. Uh I'm going to
pause here and we'll do a quiz question.
So, folks on Twitch, thank you for
asking questions. Uh I can't always see
your messages because I'm paying
attention to messages that my students
are asking
uh on the class specific
uh
chat. But um but let me try to go back
and and look at some of these questions
as well.
Um
so
This is perhaps the most active the
people have ever been in in in Twitch
chat, which is awesome.
Yeah, so um
there's a great point being made in uh
in Twitch chat uh
which is that uh
there's an assumption here that we're in
the crash model, right? Not the omission
model.
Uh so
what if there what if messages are lost,
right? So if we were in the crash model,
the algorithm that I just sketched out
would work
for implementing reliable broadcast. If
we're in the omission model, then you
would have to do something more. Uh but
it turns out that you could make this
reliable broadcast protocol work in the
omission model by also doing reliable
delivery. So assume that every one of
these messages is under the hood
actually a reliable delivery message,
which means that in practice it could be
several messages and then you wait until
you get an ack.
So you could combine this reliable
broadcast protocol with a reliable
delivery protocol and then it would also
work in the in the omission model.
Thanks for asking. That was a good
question.
All right, we'll wait a just a little
bit longer for the um for the quiz.
Whoever said in Twitch that you have to
subscribe to get your questions
answered, that's not true.
Yes, you can get your questions answered
for the low low price of $4.99 a month.
No, if I don't answer your question,
it's probably just because I didn't see
it.
So, there was a question about what's a
correct process?
Um
Right, so that depends on the fault
model, right? So, if we're working in
the crash model, a correct process is
one that doesn't crash.
If we're working in the Byzantine fault
model, then a correct process is one
that doesn't crash and doesn't exhibit
any Byzantine behavior, any arbitrary or
malicious behavior. So, this question of
what a correct process is uh is
dependent on what our fault model is.
Just like in in security, uh when
somebody says um
uh where when somebody asks the question
uh
is this system secure, right?
Well, that question of like is something
secure doesn't it really make sense out
of context. You then then you have to
ask, what is your threat model, right?
So, just like that, uh in distributed
systems, uh if you're asking, you know,
is this process correct, the question
is, well, what are the ways for a
process to be incorrect? And uh so that
that means we have to ask, what is our
fault model?
Okay.
So,
last thing I want to talk about today in
the few minutes that we have left.
Coming back to this idea that fault
tolerance often involves making copies.
Um
so
we can mitigate message loss
by making copies of messages. We've seen
that.
But, what else other than messages
do we have to be worried about maybe
losing?
Well,
in addition to message sends and
receives, right?
There's also internal events that happen
on processes.
These dots that don't have any arrows
connected to them.
And as we've talked about those those
internal events correspond to state. Ah,
somebody just said a perfect word in
chat, which is data.
We have to be worried about keeping
data.
So, processes keep state or equivalently
processes keep data, right?
So, for mitigating message loss by
making copies of messages,
how do you think we mitigate the loss of
data?
Well, we can make copies of that, too,
right?
So, maybe these processes have
a friend
who's tied to them and who has the same
data.
Or in other words, replication.
So, one thing that we talked about early
in the course, right? Is that if we have
a process
and that process has some events on it,
uh we can think of each of those events
as being a state.
And whatever our state is at a certain
point of in time is determined by all
the events that have happened up until
then.
Um
and we also have some process local
memory, right?
Uh
like maybe we have a process
and this process happens to know that
x equals 5.
Now that might be because it received a
message that said set x to 5
or maybe it got a message that said set
x to 1 and then it got four messages
that said increment x by 1. But for
whatever reason, its current state is
that x is 5. Maybe it's an entry in a
key-value store like the one that that
you're implementing uh if you're taking
the class for credit.
So we can replicate this thing with all
of its state.
So mitigating data loss is one reason to
do this. It's probably the most
important reason.
So now if one of these crashes
the fact that x is 5 isn't lost forever.
So that's the most important reason to
do replication.
Are there any other reasons why you
would want to have another copy of a
process aside from fault tolerance?
Performance, yeah. So one reason is
let's say I'm I'm here at home and
uh
I'm in California and I want to make a
request to this key-value store uh which
is running on a machine in Australia.
Um so let's say this one is in Australia
or I could make a request to its replica
which is in a data center just down the
road from me.
Um, the request to the data center
that's just down the road from me is
probably going to be faster.
No promises, right? This is the
internet. Everything's asynchronous, but
it's likely that the physically close
closer machine is the one that I will
hear from faster. So, one thing that you
can do is make a bunch of replicas and
put them in different locations around
the world
so that they'll be close to the clients
that need them.
And so then you get good data locality
in addition to to fault tolerance,
right?
And then another reason to do
replication is just dividing up the
work, right? If you're getting a lot of
messages, let's say you're getting a lot
of requests for the value of X, and
you're having a hard time handling them
all,
often it makes sense to have another
machine to take some of the burden off
of you.
So, those are all reasons to do
replication.
What we haven't talked about yet is the
significant downsides to doing
replication, uh, and that will be what
we begin with next time.
So, I'll see you on Friday.